hi I'm Harry Shum Jr and I'm Matthew
daddario and we had BuzzFeed we're about
to read read some thirst tweets from you
thirsty tweets wonderful thirsty people
tweeters it's a poem Harry Shum Jr is a
beautiful talented amazing sexy kind
honest wonderful massive hearted human
being whom of which I absolutely adore
that's very that's very pretty you
should keep that dorri dorri you wrote
this identify yourself so much I just
made up is a confidence booster and
appreciate coming onto this damn ass I
heart emojis cold shower anyone so damn
hot I swear it need a warning hashtag
hashtag typo I swear it need its I read
when you weeks before you said what's
your Twitter state tweets you don't you
can't you don't think about spelling you
don't think about grammar you don't
think about maybe this is done enough it
is like I swear
Oh hot things like life okay all cats so
beautiful so gorgeous wins the best
smile in the world owns my home who owns
my whole ass heart mr. Hirsh I'm jr. now
is your ass heart a part of your heart
oh my whole ass heart like the entirety
of all right well I like my white mother
oh you've not heard that say like my
whole ass no I didn't context but when
it's all explanation points and there's
no - and maybe whole ass is one word I
haven't had one about me oh they're
coming so here we go
Matthew Daddario really is a giant who
is all muscle and deliciously sharp
curves and he's super manly and sexy but
he's also a supersoft angel who jumps in
surprise from a dog's bark and last
cutely while petting said dog because he
really is the softest and tiniest human
but your butt for your giant you got
sharp muscles are they like sharp I
don't know siliceous leash on sharp
curves are curve just dangerous this is
amateur you're a walking danger there's
some junior is the
beautiful human being I've ever laid
eyes on with his perfect physique his
gorgeous gorgeous face and that that
vain Jay mark what's a trademark me
vanes aren't compliments what like
wasn't me up is that he's also this is
so conversation like me up is like a
huge dork with a heart of gold and he's
just so good like wow he's totally a
work of art they put the trade oh my god
they said no I didn't say it they put it
on their TM it's still thirsty they need
to they're dehydrated they need they
need from this weakness yeah they need
like it starts there yeah it's like
having a little sip and then there's
ones that literally take this big old
jug and they're like oh that's like
thirsty Jesus personally handcrafted
Matt daddario out of a huge block of
sexy your hand crafted crafted out of a
huge block of sex like yes that's that's
pretty creative oh that's pretty good yo
Malik is this get out Matthew the door
and Harry Shum Jr both so hot hey Joe
you thirsty as hell I love it thirsty
where's this been my whole life this
thirst I'm looking for this is this is
some real [ __ ] yo Malik is the Sheep now
a method already Harry Shum Jr both so
hot I love it thank you for the first
not to be that person but like isn't
everything that includes Harry Shum Jr
in it automatically sexy I don't know I
mean it's not made of a blogger site
it's not made out of it that's that sexy
right I cannot bleep okay wait it's all
be absolute I cannot believe how
believably gorgeous Matthew Quincy
daddario and Harry Shum Jr are period
I think the Twitter's known for being
like a place where there's a lot of
genius but uh but its internal screaming
though it's a well I'm not really
outside screaming we think Malik is
really the only couple who can turn me
into a mess with only a cheek kiss what
is it about other couples that are not
doing it for you look I know I know that
this is good but there are more couples
all of it you gotta check it out I know
that now I guess the best
because you know it's true but there's
gotta be more than that hero can you
find some love in the world
he wrote that one at Harry Shum Jr why
are you and at Matthew - Daria are so
hot because there's so many lights as so
many white lights we're always under
lights and it's just obviously I think
that we're in hi sweaters coming from
everybody just saying it
how does Matt Daddario manage to look
sexy and cute at the same time explain
this sorcery it's a meal what's a salsa
it's a meal what is this a meal like
it's it's some yummy oh yours okay it's
a meal it's a meal let's go with this
hot it's sex it's heaven it's some dog
hey look at that
buzz we're not least my heart beats in
Shum Daria I mean explain to me so what
happens what is this beating is it is
beating in a you know what in a language
no weird animosity way what does it
sound like where does this beat is is it
more like it's an active is it
aggressive what are we doing exactly
they were being like that oh look at
that
I'm I actually just feel really great I
feel thank you for this is this is
really nice today
keep saying nice thing yeah we really
appreciate it felt weird about it yes
tune in at 8 p.m. on Monday nights on
freeform to watch shadow on us and your
two favorite people me and Alec bye bye
bye
[Music]
[Music]